(audience cheering)
- So, we were both, we were-
(Mario speaks indistinctly)
Thank you!
So, you were at the tree lighting as well,
that's the most recent place
we were at the same place.
- That's right, that's right.
- Did you have a good time?
- I had such a good
time. It was so much fun.
I think it was like, my
eighth year doing it.
And by the way...
- Wow.
- You were awesome.
- Oh, thank you!
- You looked beautiful in that white coat!
- Thank you!
- I was like, what?
- It wasn't mine.
My stylist... It's actually,
Michaela, my stylist.
And I was supposed to wear dresses,
and last minute, I was
like, "Oh, hell no!"
- No.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I was thinking about
it because it was so...
I felt like, cryotherapy
out there, it was so cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
- How was it?
I was like, "Oh, how's she
singing with the (indistinct)?"
- Oh, I was very terrified. Yeah, yeah.
And then I was just like,
"Lord, if you love me at all...
Just like, I'll take a few notes off-key,
but if you could just
kind of keep me in line
most of the time."
- Yeah, yeah. Take the wheel!
- It was really funny.
- Barry Manilow was cool, too.
- I cried though!
The tree, I've never experienced
it physically in person.
Like, being turned on and in per...
And I didn't realize it was gonna happen.
It's so beautiful!
- It is beautiful.
The spruce...
(Kelly awes)
They call it the spruce.
- It looked like we were
in freaking Whoville!
- It did, right?
- Yes!
- I always say, it feels like
we're inside a snow globe.
- Yes!
- Right there, it's like a
Christmas movie. It's awesome.
And it kind of officially
kicks off the Christmas season,
so that was awesome.
- I know.
Savannah and Hoda were laughing at me,
'cause they were like, "Are you crying?"
And I was like, "Yes!"
(Mario laughs)
I was like, "It's so beautiful!"
- (laughs) That's awesome.
- Anyway, so do you have any
family holiday traditions
that y'all do?
- I mean, you know, we
have the family come over,
and everyone kind of
hangs out a Casa Lopez.
And my wife being Italian,
and us, of course, being a Mexican,
a lot of food, good food, hanging out.
So, we're eating a lot, drinking a lot...
- Once again, just like
Annie, invite me over.
I'll come over! Okay?
- Hey, let's do it!
- It's a big party, so we're good.
- I love Italian and Mexican food.